Archer ah better protect your bubble
calm proud sponsors of swype on Sky News
you're watching white from game tom in
germany coming up on the show this week
microsoft makes a quantum stride with
the xbox one i find out why being here
at this event could make or break a
video game and before we have to drag
ourselves home we've got a roundup of
stand out from the crowd titles hello
and welcome to swipe from gamescom one
of the biggest video gaming events
it's almost 200 albums where meters of
exhibits it letting a big name showing
off their new releases
well gamescom is a huge event last year
335,000 people turned up and this year
it's even busier how did the common Phil
Spencer thanks Gregor one of the biggest
names here is Microsoft sales of its
Xbox one so far been eclipsed by Sony's
PlayStation 4 but with their rival
deciding to give this year's game to
come a Miss Microsoft had a chance to
steal the limelight I think Xbox does a
great job of like putting the focus on
gamers putting the focus on fans really
wanting to make great games that people
are going to love to play and that's
really where you always have the best
opportunity to wow we want to make
impact one of Microsoft's biggest
announcements was DVR the ability to
record TV shows on to your console but a
new game quantum break also got plenty
of attention it's packed with stars
including x-men Shawn Ashmore and Game
of Thrones Aidan Gillen they'll also be
a TV show to run alongside it but was
all of this enough to while the critics
they did have quite a good showing they
showed up games like quantum break which
has been quiet for a long time they
should have scalebound between the time
really well this new game to platinum
but at the same time they relied really
heavily on their old favorites so tomb
raider which is now there's i guess a
little bit they relied on halo they
really were pushing Windows 10 it seemed
like they were just not announcing
anything new one of the other big beasts
at Gamescom is electronic arts they're
best known for making sports games like
the FIFA series but recently they've
branched out into different genre
we were given a glimpse of star wars
battlefront and the puzzle game unravel
featuring a fluffy character called yani
I think it sits nicely inside the
Electronic Arts family and it's
something that I think is important for
the company not only as a single title
but also both internally and externally
I think it helps EA to become a little
bit more personal Navy gamescom isn't
just about new games oculus are here
with their virtual reality headset and
HTC have turned out with this the vibe
something they hope will be hugely
popular with gamers the reaction we've
gotten so far just people using the dev
kit and going through the demos has been
overwhelming probably of any product
I've ever been around I've never seen
people walk around walk out with such it
you know my god I can't believe what I
just saw a type of feeling now obviously
you know we've got to translate that
into a number of different applications
that deliver that same experience but
I'm confident the products going to
deliver upon that so how important is
games come to the video games industry
Gemma's been finding out guy your a
games expert and journalist you and your
colleagues travel from all over the
world to be here at Gamescom why is it
such a big deal there's a few major
events on the gaming calendar III couple
months ago in June is where all the big
games are announced but games call me
here in Cologne in Germany is where
250,000 people get to play those games
for the first time and myself as a
journalist I get to play a lot these
games for the first time that's why I
rack up those air miles coming to these
sorts of show is it a make-or-break
situation for the games makers so they
have to get their titles seen here
for them to be a success yeah I mean the
big games that come out on platforms
like PlayStation 4 and Xbox one they
have to get them in the hands of
consumers because those consumers have
to decide whether they're going to spend
50 pounds sixty pounds on where they're
going to buy these games so they travel
250,000 people travel specifically to
these shows to get those hands on queue
for hours a lot of the time and decide
where they're going to spend 60 quid 60
quid on games that they're you know for
the next year and not just big name
makers you've got the indie space titles
too yeah I mean the games markets
changed a lot over the last few years
you've got mobile titles these sort of
titles that we're looking at around us
big pc games big console games the
trouble within these spaces they don't
have a lot of money to spend on coming
to these sorts of events so those indie
gems like Minecraft and candy crush and
angry birds are more difficult to find a
trade events like this these events
still as fresh every year that they feel
new watch Anna I've been coming for
about 10 years two events in germany and
the US and the sort of sense of malaise
does set in a little bit you get guitar
hero which was big a few years ago
coming back I mean a good game but
coming back saying game we play before
metal gear solid 5 lots and lots of
seeking telling us to you getting bull
I'm getting bored thanks time to quit
Jaron it's time to get out of this I'm
gonna try go and try and get find those
indie gems yeah these sorts of trade
shows there that's the sense of kind of
riskiness and innovation isn't really
here at these trade shows so when it
gained my can travel from EA about a
tiny little creature made of wool that's
really unique and a novel and journalist
like myself you know we applaud for that
sort of stuff okay so you're not
quitting you're just changing your focus
I changed my focus yeah thanks a ton
thanks yeah there's someone else here
you're watching swype still to come we
get hands-on with some of this year's
you
the first is a mini round up in some of
this week's other techniques
thunderbirds are go who'd of thought
clips of this legendary 1960s puppet
series will become part of a Kickstarter
project in 2015 a documentary producer
is raising funds to create three brand
new episodes of the classic Thunderbirds
series using original voice tracks and
retro production techniques it's a way
of celebrating the 50th anniversary it's
a long way from puppetry but this quirky
robots turn on crowdfunding site
IndieGoGo seems to have been going so
well it's been extended buddy described
as a hands-free helper interacts with
you and your family among other things
he can answer calls patrol the rooms in
your home give you dinner suggestions
and play your favorite music buddy turn
on the lights but one robot hasn't fared
so well this week hitch box had
successfully hitchhiked across Canada
and parts of Europe before beginning its
latest journey in Massachusetts last
month but two weeks on the robot was
decapitated and dismembered on the
streets of Philadelphia he's not holding
it against humanity though hitchbot
tweeted my love for humans will never
fade
there really is so much to have a go on
and with loads of news idle who would
even dry and Whittle it down to a few
favorites
well as it's our right well star wars
battlefront for a start they show off
the new fighter squadron mode here at
Gamescom they announced they weren't
going to be having space battles in star
wars battlefront that disappointed a lot
of people but what I do have is dog
fighting between excellent and tie
fighters in kind of low orbit so you're
above a planet with x-wings & Tie
Fighters it's dog fighting you've got
lasers flying everywhere things
exploding it's incredibly frantic
they're like super exciting and there's
objectives there's it's 10 vs 10 so 10
x-wings 10 typewriters they've also got
10 AI ships of each kind so the sky is
absolutely full of spaceships there's
objectives is supposed to destroy true
transporters things like that but there
are also pickups that you can get to
turn you into kind of iconic spaceships
from the Star Wars universe so the level
we were playing on had a pickup to turn
you into the Millennium Falcon's for
example so you can finally get a chance
to pilot the Millennium Falcon which I
think I've wanted to do since I was
about 5
I've also played some of call of duty
black ops 3 multiplayer here at Gamescom
which which was really cool it's
interesting they changed the traversal
method for the game in this so they
added double jumps in advanced warfare
but now it's more of a there's a meter
for how you can move so you can jump up
and then still of dart left where you
can dart right you can use it to slide
along the ground so they're trying to
kind of mix up the way you move around
the levels which is cool and also you
play as different opportunities this
time which have different abilities that
they're sort of the way you earn a
tightening titanfall by playing the game
you earn these abilities so one
character his arm turns into a minigun
and other ones got these gravity spikes
that he slams into the ground and they
make a big area of effect the tag so I
think it's going to that's going to have
quite an impact on the way that people
play call of duty i mean the gravity
spikes particularly in something like
domination is going to be super useful
for capturing the flag and also for a
bit of Mirror's Edge catalyst which is
the sequel to the first mirrors edge
which was kind of a and overlooks
classic a bit a lot of people really
like the game but it didn't sell super
well guys to using this opportunity to
make the sequel into the kind of
building on what they did in the first
game and adding a bunch of stuff so it's
got a more overt story this time and
they've changed the controls of it the
traversals a bit easy to get head around
I'm here they're taking guns out of the
game as well so the combat is now really
based around the freerunning it's about
avoiding people and then striking when
you get the opportunity I think it's
gonna be something that's quite
different from a lot of the other games
that are out there I think it's one word
pecan island well that then they began
they going to find use on mobile and I
had some bonus features
both of you
and I fell by gotcha ah better protect
your bubble com proud sponsors of swype
on Sky News